basically communism fed off of the
Soviet Union until it killed it and then
it transferred over to China and now
it's sucking the brain of China and it's
trying to get into the United States is
it trying to kill China like split it up
into a bunch of what hyper capitalist
States and just be gone with it that was
very backwards well like you're saying
like the Soviet Union's like haha we
never really left like the Communist
aspect of it never really left the world
it just moved from country to Country
just like the war machine moved from the
Republican party to the Democrat Party
communism's finding a home in different
superpowers or has been over the last
hundred years but to the left even know
how the communism in the Soviet Union
was like they were not pro LGBT or any
of that stuff
yeah and these uh and Che Guevara you
know that guy was was a bigot but these
these leftists who are like whoa
communism they'd be the people who would
be breaking rocks first
they're the ones who get arrested locked
up and then go break rocks to figure out
what hard work is like